breaking news here at home the manager
of a local bar run over by robbery
suspect that suspect still at large this
all unfolding near flamingo and jones
and that's where we find victoria saha
live with the latest details victoria
ryan denise the parking lot here still a
very active scene as police continue to
interview witnesses to get a clearer
picture of that suspect that ran over
the manager at dottie's here's what we
know so far police say a black man in
his 20's to 30's entered dottie's this
evening and sat down in front of a poker
machine where he then snatched a woman's
purse and ran the female manager in her
60's went after him outside to confront
him this is when police say the suspect
pulled out a gun the manager then went
behind his car but the suspect put his
car in reverse and ran her over before
driving away the manager died at the
hospital
right now suspect is wanted for one
count of open murder and also for the
strong armed robbery that occurred
inside the business
metro police still working to see if
this suspect was a regular at the
dotties police did not give a
description of the car this area of the
parking lot is expected to be closed at
least for the next few hours if you have
any information regarding this please
contact police reporting live tonight
victoria saha live local now